[Musique]
la 104 et death rival reconnu est
nécessaire de la renault 5 ps depuis la
sortie de la coupe et 5 chevaux 100 4 il
ya deux ans correspond à une clientèle
plus sportifs coûtant 20 mille sept cent
cinquante francs clé en main soit 150
francs de moins que sa concurrente
directe 7 6 chevaux sportive maniable et
très accrocheuse sur la route consomme
un peu plus de 8 à 100 kilomètres à
l'heure
un reproche pourtant son tableau de bord
triste et peu accessibles à l'oeil
lorsque vous roulez 7,2 porte très
nerveuse plus courte de 20 cm que la
renault 5 a bien entendu aussi tous les
inconvénients des petites voitures un
habitacle réduit et peut recommander
pour une petite famille elle sortira
néanmoins au rythme de 68 par jour à
peugeot mulhouse là où l'a 104 est née
il ya plus de trois ans et l'on espère
du côté de la filiale mulhousienne que
son succès sera aussi impressionnant que
celui de la six enquêtes dont les délais
de livraison vont en s'accroissant
on parle beaucoup de peugeot mulhouse en
ce moment est-ce que tout va bien est ce
que il se pose des problèmes
actuellement je vais faudrait des
composés si si l'on prend l'aspect
économique en fonction de certains
indices très faible on pourrait
peut-être estimé que nous abordons la
convalescence après la période produire
que nous connaissons depuis la fin de
l'année 73
nous espérons que ces indices vont se
confirmer et que nous allons dans les
prochains mois pour reprendre une légère
progression
voilà sur le plan économique sur le plan
social
vous connaissez d'une manière très
générale la position et les
revendications très globale de
l'ensemble des syndicats
depuis nous ont peut-être quelques
petits problèmes particuliers au 31 août
dernier l'effectif de peugeot mulhouse
s'élevait exactement à dix mille sept
cent soixante seize personnes soit 4
cents de moins qu'au plus fort de 1973
et la production à 540 véhicules
terminés et 2300 boîtes de vitesses par
jour le terme de convalescence
correspond parfaitement à ces chiffres
et la direction s'enorgueillit
aujourd'hui de n'avoir pas trop mal
traversé dit-elle les deux années de
crise économique
d'ailleurs il est toujours question
d'extension detroit 113 hectares
existants sans plus de
précisions quant aux syndicats leur
réclamation reste d'ordre général 40
heures de travail par semaine et la
retraite à 60 ans entre autres alors que
la cfdt mène en plus actuellement une
campagne contre la répression syndicale
la direction y répond par des chiffres
260 tracts syndicaux distribué l'an
dernier 200 5 depuis le 1er janvier de
cette année donc pas d' entrave au
syndicalisme enfin il est beaucoup
question actuellement de l'amélioration
des tâches consistant à éliminer entre
autres le travail à la chaîne a humanisé
en quelque sorte ces tâches
nous avons lancé un certain nombre
d'expériences qui concerne actuellement
entre sept et huit cents personnes
nous avons déjà des résultats et je
crois qu il est impossible de donner un
bilan d'un seul mot nous avons des
réussites
nous avons des réussites partielles et
nous avons
un échec
notre conclusion cependant c'est que il
serait souhaitable d'avoir la
possibilité d'offrir différentes
méthodes de travail en fonction des
souhaits des individus en fonction de
leurs capacités
mais cela ce n'est pas toujours possible
la renault va bien sûr vous connaissez
mais pas cette nouvelle ds à moteur 2
litres entièrement inédit c'est un
événement rarissime qui mérite une
information plus complète
première originalité un bloc aluminium
plus légers d'environ 20 kilos une
courroie 30 et plus silencieuse qu'une
chaîne de distribution entraîne l'arbre
à cames en tête
remarquez l'allumeur horizontale les
soupapes en v et les chambres de
combustion hémisphérique enfin un
carburateurs double corps et une pompe
pour la direction assistée montée en
syrie
ce très beau 4 cylindres 2 litres
développe 110 chevaux réel tout en
restant très souple à bas régime
ceci au prix d'une consommation
relativement modérée et sur la route
il en résulte un bilan très satisfaisant
confort silence performance tenue de
route
mais le freinage ne suit pas et manque
trop nettement d'endurance dommage car
pour 39 1700 enfants c'est de 21s a de
quoi séduire
[Musique]
entre la banalité d'un utilitaire et le
snobisme coûteux d'un tout terrain une
nouvelle génération d'automobiles voie
actuelle dans le jour celle des
tout-terrains de plaisance et par
l'intermédiaire de matra simca chrysler
se lance dans l aventure avec le rancho
un véhicule très original plutôt break
étudié à partir d'une base sim car en ce
sens avec moteur de la 308
[Musique]
admirez l'exotisme dans les moindres
détails des pneumatiques large un énorme
pare chocs
les phares bien à l'abri des projecteurs
orientable and options de volumineuses
protections latérales des grandes baies
vitrées
à l'arrière une galerie de toit et une
visière pare-soleil essuie glace arrière
et crochets de remorques en séries en
break
le volume de chargement dépasse 2 mètres
cubes mais le rancho offre également
cinq places avec les bagages à l'abri
des regards
[Musique]
bien sûr il est fort tentant de
s'aventurer en tout terrain
ceci malgré le handicap des seules roues
avant motrices et en l'absence de
différentiel autobloquant
[Musique]
hélas heureuse surprise
il faut dire que grâce à la bonne garde
au sol plus de 21 cm et à une excellente
suspension le rancho passe fort bien et
même assez vite dans les plus mauvais
endroit et tout cela dans un remarquable
confort
[Musique]
mais si la vie est belle en terrain sec
tout se gâte hélas sur le mouillé ou le
rancho se plante disons assez facilement
là une seule solution déroulé le treuil
à commande électrique trouver un arbre
solide et diriger la manoeuvre du bout
des doigts
mais ce treuil forte utile est encore à
l'étude et ne sera commercialisé que
l'an prochain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
conclusion pour trente six mille francs
le rancho c'est vraiment l'auto verte
qui voit la vie en rose
lorsque le ciel est bleu
[Musique]
une fois de plus
révolution à sochaux mais une voiture de
classe moyenne aux lignes agréable dont
la carrosserie est dérivé du véhicule
expérimental de sécurité peugeot
première impression lorsqu'on s'assoit
derrière le volant de la 305 c'est le
confort confort du aux dimensions de
l'habitacle à l'avant comme à l'arrière
confort aussi dû aux moteurs à
l'extraordinaire souplesse du moteur
sur autoroute la conduite de la 305 et
sans problème ont atteint plus de 155 km
heure avec la version 8 chevaux et
facilement 145 km heure avec la 7
chevaux ont conduite classique la
voiture et neuf dans les virages à
grande vitesse et la tendance à
s'échapper vers l'extérieur des courbes
ce qui est normal pour une traction
avant
ce qui l'est moins c'est que sur route
mouillée cette tendance devient un
défaut on peut assister alors à des
pertes d'adhérence importante du train
avant lorsqu'on prend un virage un peu
vite le freinage assisté avec disques à
l'avant et tambours à l'arrière est
suffisant pour les 13 150 kg de la
voiture en pleine charge placée
transversalement le moteur en aluminium
est soit un trail sens qui développe 65
chevaux soit 1 15 174 chevaux
neuf chevaux de plus de 15 cents
beaucoup plus souple consomme moins
entre 7 et 9 litres aux cent alors que
l'on atteint les 10 litres avec le 13
cents tous les éléments sont très
accessibles pour les réparations avec un
bon point supplémentaire pour la boîte
de fusible la roue de secours placés
sous le coffre laisse un bon volume pour
les bagages à l'intérieur on peut
regretter que les dossiers des sièges
avant sur la version de base soit fixe
mais bravo au tableau de bord et à la
climatisation très efficace est d'un
maniement simple en option un toit
ouvrant dont le système d'ouverture et
pratique
en conclusion nous donnerons à la
nouvelle peugeot trois bons points et un
mauvais point les mauvais point pour le
manque d'adhérence du train avant sur
sol mouillé les trois bons points qui
devraient satisfaire une bonne majorité
de la clientèle visée
le confort la souplesse des deux moteurs
et la faible consommation
reste à savoir si la 305 sera comme ses
grandes soeurs une vedette des rallyes
africains preuve d'une construction
solide
pour la première fois un constructeur
français a vendu plus d'un million de
voitures à l'étranger en un an
devinez qui c'est renault et renault
pour renforcer sa vocation et sa
nécessité d'exporter vient aussi de
signer un accord avec le quatrième
constructeur américain american motors
un accord pour vendre des voitures aux
etats-unis mais aussi pour monter des
voitures et notamment la bientôt fameuse
r18 la r18 dont vous avez peu entendu
parler mais que la régie lance
aujourd'hui sur le marché s'inscrit tout
à fait dans cette politique c'est une
voiture classique
un futur fer de lance de renault à
l'étranger elle sera construite
également dans plusieurs pays européens
les r18 ne va pas remplacer tout de
suite la r12 ou la r16 comme on l'a dit
ce sera peut être vrai dans quelques
années
la r18 se situe un tout autre niveau que
les autres modèles que je viens de citer
jean louis burgat en a fait l'essai et
il a beaucoup apprécié ce dernier enfant
de la régie renault et c'est jean-louis
burgat la 18 ont fait ces quatre
voitures un cocktail de deux moteurs et
de deux finitions dont les prix
s'étendent de 29000 à 35 mille cinq
cents francs
la tl moteur 14 centimètres cubes sept
chevaux la gtl même moteur mais finition
luxe la ts moteur 16 150 centimètres
cubes neuf chevaux
la gts enfin avec le moteur 16 150 la
finition luxe mais aussi une boîte 5
vitesses en plus sur la ts et la gts
renault propose une boîte automatique en
option
sur route vote surprise le comportement
d'une traction avant bien équilibré
légèrement sous vireuse c'est normal
avec des vitesses maxi volontairement
limité entre 150 et 160 suivant les
modèles enfin des reprises moyenne sur
l'a7 chevaux bonne sur l'a9 chevaux
elles correspondent à des rapports de
pont assez long en vue de réduire la
consommation et c'est efficace puisque
avec la 7 chevaux sur un circuit route
autoroute ville en ne ménageant pas
l'accélérateur je n'ai jamais dépassé 9
litres 50 au sens pour la 9 chevaux avec
la boîte 5 vitesses
la consommation peut être inférieure
encore de près d'un litre
côté négatif une direction un peu lourde
à basse vitesse et un niveau sonore à
améliore quant au freinage disque à
l'avant tambour à l'arrière je n'ai
jamais pu le prendre en défaut et ils
ont fait fort bien ce bilan routier très
satisfaisant à l'intérieur une finition
bonne tableau de bord complet mais
abandon définitif du compte-tours et
absence gênante de tablettes sous le
pare brise la position au volant et le
confort des sièges avant et arrière sont
remarquables incontestablement à la
régie ont misé gros sur la 18 qui
s'attaque à ce marché des voitures
moyennes avec coffre séparé de
l'habitacle qui constitue 50 2% des
ventes en europe
avec ses 4 m 38 de long 15 cm de plus
que la 305 son pont arrière rigide
cette traction avant et de conception
très classique mais cela doit garantir
sa solidité et la facilité du montage à
l'étranger pour un modèle à vocation
internationale
renault avait voulu construire un
produit homogène en définitive je crois
que le pari a été tenu
la 18è sur le marché européen et dans
cette gamme de voitures moyennes
vraisemblablement le meilleur compromis
entre le confort les performances
le prix et la consommation un peu mal
cette voiture mais jean-louis blot café
d'intention conduisait d'une main vous
gardez les caméras de l'eau c'est pas
bien
[Musique]